Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P, I am shocked by the outpouring
of messages yesterday on the bonus show yesterday.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Right. We made money on the bonus show
yesterday and we talked about manual transmissions
in cars. And I said my first vehicle when I got
my license was a 1991 Pontiac Firebird. And I
know you would not expect a Jewish Argentinean
to be driving a Pontiac Firebird. Culturally,
it doesn't make any sense. I get it, guys, but
that was my first car. I got a great deal on it,
I have to tell you. And I indicated that for me,
it's sort of sad that manual transmissions are
going away, particularly with electric vehicles
which don't even have gearboxes. We are seeing
a decline in the number of available available
vehicles with a manual transmission. This is not
you know, this is not kids going hungry. It's just
an element of nostalgia. And I said yesterday that
I didn't love it. I got so many emails from
people saying, David, I love stick shifts.
Here's how here's how you could do this. That
the other thing and here is a piece of advice
that I got about this stick shift issue.
Speaker 2: Yes. Hello, David, this is yeah,
that's from Marietta, Georgia. Please. I
heard your show. I heard your bonus show.
I heard your manual transmission. Well, I don't
know, Jeremiah. I don't know what it is meant.
It was. Motorcycles. I got one word
for you. Motorcycles. They could be
manual transmission is going to be on motorcycles
for as long as I can imagine. I got to believe it.
So. And by the way, one of my favorite films
based out of origin, Argentina. Yes. Is Motorcycle
Diaries, right? I don't know if you ever saw
it, but man, what a great, fantastic film. But
I learned in the 1960s to drive a stick shift on
the steering wheel on the handle as well as for on
the floor. I know manual very well and I love it.
Speaker 1: All right. So, listen, here's the deal.
I don't know how many people in the audience
know this. I used to have a motorcycle
when I was I want to say about 18. I bought
a used Honda, CBR 600 from a friend of mine.
It was so cool. It was fine. It was
great. And then one day I just realized,
this is absolutely insane. This is so dangerous.
This is crazy. And I sold the motorcycle, and I
never looked back. And now, in particular, knowing
a bunch of emergency room doctors and hearing from
them, listen, you don't get a motorcycle. It's
insanely dangerous. I know you only live once and
all this different stuff. It seems like an insane
risk. So I get it. Stick shift on motorcycles.
It's a beautiful thing. It's not going to be
for me. It is just so outrageously dangerous.
And I'm not denying that it's fun.
I'm not denying that it's great,
but it's not for me. So for me, my stick
shift driving will be limited to, I think,
at a certain point if and when, you know, my
household needs a second vehicle, I think I would
prioritize something with a manual transmission
for nostalgia purposes. Okay. Thank you very much.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about the
results from last night's primaries in Wisconsin,
Minnesota, Vermont and Connecticut. We are going
to talk about an attempt by U.S. lawmakers to
crack down on airlines for canceled flights. It
is bonkers what's been happening with canceled
flights recently. And we are also going to bring
back the discussion about a national popular vote.
It is now abundantly clear most Americans
support a national popular vote. They just do.
And there are a number of different ways
that we can get there, some easier than
others. We will talk about the pros and the cons
of a national popular vote, of using the popular
vote to decide who becomes president of the United
States. All of those stories and much, much more
await you on today's bonus show. You can sign up
for the bonus show at. Join Pacman dot com. You
can use the coupon code. Big voting 22. Something
we must all do to get a discount off of the cost
of a membership. So I will see you on the bonus
show today or otherwise on tomorrow's show.